we're going to have a very short program
and we have a walk around Mike so you
can ask a lot of questions we've got two
real experts tonight on the vehicle mile
miles travel charge or fee or whatever
you want to call it and maybe they can
talk about what we might call it first
is Johannes mud and she is with the RAND
Corporation I could go down a long list
of achievements of Johanna but just love
you saying that she's written a lot and
been involved for some time with all
kinds of research and she's a research
manager and traveled behavior and in its
impacts and the focus on passenger and
freight deta hai behind me too over my
right shoulder is Adrian more he's vice
president of research for the reason
foundation used my boss I could probably
spend you know 15 minutes introducing
him but that's probably not the best
thing to do but he's also co-author saw
of you that were here last year Sam's
daily was the speaker he's co-author in
the book mobility first among others
including one on transit by the way and
but well we'll leave that all four for
later discussion if you're interested
and with that I don't know who if you
all decided who's going first obviously
Adrian and with that and please join in
like I said we have a walk around Mike's
as you can ask questions and
again thank you very much for coming and
thank you for being at the reason office
thank you yeah I think the secret to
being a real expert on something is to
find something that we know nothing
about and then you can read like two
articles and you're leading expert on it
and you know we don't know a whole lot
about mileage-based user fees so the bar
is low the you know is my starting point
for thinking about this issue is that
people love to get things for free but
there's really only one way you get
things for free in our typical modern
life and that's when politicians give
you free stuff in exchange for your vote
that's really the only source of free
stuff out there everything else you get
you pretty much have to pay for and of
course you really do pay for the free
stuff that you get from the government
but it looks like it's free and you know
people are in the rest of their lives
they're perfectly willing to pay for
things if the thing they're paying for
is worth the amount they're asked to pay
if it's not worth it they don't buy it
that's a fundamental decision we make
without thinking one second about it a
dozen times a day but it's embedded in
our day to day life which brings me to
the gas tax
people don't know how much gas tax they
pay they have no idea what they're
getting for their gas tax construction
that you don't drive through is as mid
the coldest values Battlestar Galactica
it just doesn't exist so the idea that
your money is going to build some things
that are not on your day-to-day route is
whatever its it Smith do you don't know
how much you paid on what's going for
you know it the gas tax overcame that
hurdle back in the day when the
advantage it has was it was a really
cheap way to collect revenue it was a
fairly decent indirect user fee so
people's consumption of gasoline was
very closely related to their use of the
roads and so as a way of collecting
money from people in order to pay for
the roads it made a lot of sense over
time that connection has eroded now I'm
an economist and I know we got a very
mixed group here only you know a
fraction of you or economist but you can
either just trust economist silly don't
do that but economist will argue that
user fees are a better way of paying for
things than taxes because taxes suffer
from this sort of there's a lot of
things but they suffer from sort of a
disassociation people tend with taxes
not to know what they're paying or know
what they're getting for it does that
sound familiar with fees you generally
have some idea when you pay X to get
into a park that's a fee you have an
idea i'm getting into Yelp Yellowstone
Park and I'm paying X to get in there
you know the gas tax hasn't really
function like that for a long time it's
been much more like a tax we pay it we
don't know
kind of no we pay it when you buy cast
but we don't know how much it is and we
don't know where it goes and we don't
know how much goes to to wear or any of
that so it's like it acts like a taps at
the same time we've for many reasons
decided we want to consume less gas some
people want to consume less gas because
of greenhouse gas emissions and some
policymakers want to try to convince us
or even force us to consume less gas
because of greenhouse gases some people
want to consume less gas because it
costs of being much money and it's
probably going to cost more money in the
future so we would really like to spend
less of our precious resources on gas
you know we'd like to consume less gas
firm we don't want to be so dependent on
foreign oil many reasons out there why
different people might want to consume
less gas which means that we are
steadily and surely applying our
technology innovations to figuring out
ways we can drive more while using less
gas which means we're using more road
while we're paying less for the roads I
think you can see there is a problem
there over time as you look forward 20
years into the future that gap just
keeps growing and we keep having an ever
increasing problem we're using the roads
more and we're paying less to use them
roads are not getting cheaper and so
there's there's a disconnect there so
the gas tax is problematic as we go into
the future as a way to pay for
transportation so what do we do well as
an economist I I really take to heart
and I think generally speaking common
sense dictates that a user fee is better
we could say we'll look as the gas tax
kind of fades away we're just going to
have to increase income tax
sir sales taxes or whatever its its tax
we're going to keep taxing people to pay
for the road but then that means you
know there's no more user fee there
isn't a system where the money that
we're paying for the roads like it does
right now goes into a trust fund that
generally gets used for well does get
used for transportation purposes even if
it doesn't all get used for roads
there's a real there is still a real
connection between what you spend what
you use in cept in a few states like my
state California which they just use it
for whatever the hell they want you know
parties for the government and the a
user fee keeps you sort of in the space
where the money is is tracked and
visible and accountable for being used
for transportation so there's a big
event what's the user fee of the future
thats going could conceivably replace
the gas tax well it is a mile based user
fee now there's a few issues with that
there has some fantastic advantages it
is a pure user fee paying by the mile
for using the roads it's just like
paying an entrance fee into a park or
paying by the pound for apples or
everything else we buy in private
markets at least as a starting point
there's you know there's issues with
setting those prices and things like
that which all economists can geek out
on but we'll leave that aside and just
say it had it's sort of an ideal user
fee in a lot of ways it's a few has some
issues well number one probably too many
of you is privacy right that I think the
common conception of a mileage based
user fee means that means somebody is
keeping track of every where you drive
all the time in charging you for where
you drive all the time right I think
many people in government would love
that kind of system may be plenty of
people here would love that kind of
system anybody who's a data geek would
love that kind of system because Oh
wouldn't we all love to know have real
data instead of this modeling nonsense
now to tell us where people go when and
why but people aren't most people are
not fans of having the government or
really anybody else know everywhere they
drive people buy these on star systems
which clearly if when you crash you in a
tree that calls the ambulance it must
know where you are therefore you are in
fact being tracked but the reality is is
that that system is not tracking you in
real time because they can't make any
money off of that they only make money
off of sending an ambulance to you when
you crash so they just only talk to your
car when it does that but there are many
technologies available right now that
will keep track on board the car of
where you go and when you go and will
only report out how much money you owe
and nobody but you and your car ever
know where you went it's very easy
technologically devised that we have
several existing technologies that can
do that we just have to actually do that
and not let you know some crazy people
impose some kind of system that tracks
us I think that's a fairly manageable
challenge but a very important one
second it's expensive collecting the gas
tax costs about point four cents per
dollar it's a very cheap tax it may be
one of the cheapest taxes we have you
know if you're a fan of cheap taxes the
tolling you know regular old for those
of you who've used a toll road anywhere
here on the East Coast there's a lot of
difference in the cost of those systems
but the most efficient ones out there
are about five cents per dollar
collected so 20 times that right
yeah 20 times the cost of the gas tax a
mileage based system couldn't be that
efficient anytime in the conceivable you
know in the short free future it take
quite a while to get there so we're
talking more like 10 or 12 cents per
dollar for a system like this at least
initially wow that's burning a lot more
of your money on collection than it is
on on actually having revenue there's
many dimension there's a lot of other
issues we could talk about but I don't
want to get into guys 1 raise those is
the two big ones the the challenge we
have is I see that gas tax Delta
becoming a significant problem in about
10 years in a gigantic problem in 20
years meanwhile we're not you know
dealing well with the problems we
currently have transportation funding
people in government and and the private
sector even tend to say oh we need more
revenue you know the needs are twice
what the revenue is coming in you need
more revenue and they're starting at the
end of the problem you know look people
don't want to pay more in gas taxes
because they'll only pay more for
something if they think they're getting
more they all believe they're getting
less than what they're they're getting
bad value for the money they're
currently paying until people believe
really believe it can see really see
that the money they're spending is doing
the right things and it's doing it
efficiently and effectively in other
words State v OTS and local translation
agencies start getting efficient and
effective and start doing good projects
and not nonsense political projects and
all these things that's a high hurdle to
jump but nobody's going to trust that
system and give it more money until that
happens so talking about raising the
amount of money people pay is
extraordinarily premature a best and
just plain wrong if you haven't figured
out already how to get the most bang for
the buck you're already collecting you
have no business
skiing for more so people rightfully
demand that the system gets better long
before anybody asks them to pay more and
in that time span is when I think we're
looking at having to replace the gas tax
at this much be so where it's a long run
very complex transition which leads to
Johannes talk which she's brand has done
a lot of work on how a might such a
transition actually work Thank You
Adrian I'm Adrian and I actually had a
method to this madness of what we're
presenting here today he was going to do
what he does best which is lay out these
issues and I'm going to do what I do
best would just talk about research so
so the two studies I'm talking about
today our studies that Rand has
conducted in the last three years for
sponsored by the Transportation Research
Board and ashta the first was a team led
by ran that investigated alternative
mechanisms for looking at transition to
mileage-based user user fees in the
short term so basically answering the
question what could we do in the next
five years the second study sort of was
a follow-on study that out outlined a
plan for large-scale system trials that
looked at the most promising concepts
coming out of the first day that study
actually the report on that second study
was released in late 2010 and it was
used by staffers to in their work on the
reauthorization legislation so we many
several of the researchers went up there
and briefed on the hell I don't know
we're going to see anything from that
but we'll see so what did the first so
you find out the headline of that study
is that and I'm going to use the acronym
we all have jargons right so I'm going
to you avoided it but I'm going to use
it mileage base user fee the act the
acronym is in buff and I'm going to
music's is just easier so what did the
first study fine basically ended up in
buff is promising and technically
feasible now what did we base that
assessment of technically feasible on
ran and assess eight metering options
for VMT monitoring three relied on
odometer based checks 302 were
relatively simple automatic vehicle
identification or ABI devices that could
communicate with towing gantries or fuel
tanks and three or more sophisticated
onboard units that incorporated
communications with an onboard
diagnostic port selling cellular
communications our gps receiver so what
did we find out all of them are
technically feasible for collecting
mileage-based user fees some that all of
them have limitations and how you view
those limitations
really depended on what policy options
your most in you were most concerning
with for instance GPS receivers were the
most flexible they had the broadest
range of monitoring capabilities but
they were the most expensive and also
had generated the greatest privacy
concerns on the other hand odometer
based checks were the least expensive
but had the narrowest range of
monitoring capabilities so the rand
researchers basically concluded that
while the technical feasibility of
mileage base user fees is there there
are other issues that aren't technically
related that need to be developed before
this can be rolled out in the national
system these have to do with collecting
revenues how to deal with preventing
evasion how to
do in public acceptance and public
acceptance actually turned out to be an
important point so the second following
follow-on study was started and as I
mentioned in 2010 and that asked and
answered the question what would
large-scale trials look like it was the
eye shadow said that the first study
concluded that these issues that needed
to be investigated really needed
large-scale trials to get the required
level or scale in order to really see
how they would play out in practice the
trials that have been done before we're
all basically focused on technical
feasibility and so they had very small
samples maybe a couple hundred or a
couple thousand vehicles so we needed
these large-scale trials to really make
a decision on whether this could be
rolled out as a national system so in
conducting the second study we talked to
experts stakeholders held an expert
panel workshop and looked at the issues
that really need to be incorporated into
these large-scale trials and basically
two issues rose to the top one dealing
with the scope of the trials and the
second one dealing with the
institutional framework for rolling it
out so I'll deal with the scope of the
trials first basically our research
determine that the trial should be
rolled out in
26 states or groups of adjacent States
and that the funding for the trial
should be competitively awarded we also
we also determined that that the trial
should last for 26 years two years for
planning three years for the trial and
one year for evaluation and assessment
and that collectively the trials should
include a 50,000 to 100,000 vehicles
remember before this I said the trials
or pilots to date had that the most a
couple thousand vehicles so what we're
suggesting there's trials that would be
in the neighborhood of 10,000 to 20,000
vehicles for trial the trial should
address or look at both passenger and
freight and travel and also should focus
on the GPS media metering devices but
shouldn't neglect the other devices
based on what we think the important
policy issues are reducing an
implementation costs or having the
broadest range of functionality the
trial should incorporate multiple
mechanisms for collecting revenues
looking
preventing evasion and also protecting
privacy so we're laying out a pretty
extensive scope for these trials and the
costs that were estimated to do this
we're between range between a hundred
million and 400 million given the cost
we also suggested that the management
and over site of the trials should
include three different entities first a
national panel that would deal with
high-level policy issues a working group
that would do it with technical issues
and third sort of separate entities or
agencies that would actually carry out
the pilots so believe it or not the sort
of scoping issues were simple in
comparison to really thinking through
the institutional framework for rolling
this out to address this three
frameworks were put forth first a
federal lid framework this is one where
it would start with the federal charge
and the states could piggyback on that
second is a state-led charge that would
really encourage States to experiment
this interoperability came forth it was
established and third was a market-based
framework that would allow device
manufacturers to compete to provide
value-added services in a value added in
a voluntary system all three have pros
and cons so the pros of the federal
system is that it would directly address
the need to augment federal
transportation revenues it would
maximize opportunities to reduce costs
through economies of scale and it would
ensure interoperability but there are
cons the biggest con is that would
we require national political consensus
and this is a pregnant pause require
mandatory adoption which would compound
the difficulties of gaining public
acceptance the state the pros of the
State led framework is that the big
thing is that it would be easier to gain
public acceptance of individual states
for at the individual state level than
at the national level the cons are that
it would not especially in the near term
address national or federal
transportation revenue shortfalls and
there would be risk that the systems
would not be interoperable across states
and it would reduce the chances for
reduced cause through economies of scale
so third is the market based framework
and the pros the number one pro is that
it would reduce the running costs big
bro and it would maximize social value
by offering value added services in a
voluntary system and so you have a more
voluntary system another Pro would be
that it is conceivable that public
acceptance would be greater for the
market-based system the cons are that it
basically assumes that there is this
market for these value-added services in
a voluntary system that's not been
played
out yet and that it would require an
initial set of interoperability
standards and a certification process
for these private vendors prior to the
start of trials so basically there's
which payment for the desk there's
little agreement among the 70 quest
experts that we've talked with and part
of the reason there's little agreement
is there's that there's these three
parallel computing goals one is enabling
the development of a national system
second is allowing states to proceed
rapidly and third is exploring
competition among firms looking at
various value-added services and
voluntary adoption strategies so we're
possibly leaning toward a framework that
would blend elements of each right now
it looks like we're leaning towards
either a state or a market-based
framework but anything or nothing is
possible I'll just close with an update
on what's going on in the various states
now Minnesota has trials beginning this
summer Oregon has a legislation that
would require inba for electric vehicles
by 2015 Texas and Nevada are rolling out
odometer based trials Colorado is in the
planning for a trial the i-95 corridor
coalition is looking at a three-state
trial that would be Maryland Delaware
and Pennsylvania and finally New York
City has is gathering information right
now for a market-based trial well start
the questions and you can direct it to
either one and i'm sitting down and so
our guy I'd like to thank the speakers
or then it loose in presentations my
question is why the need for a national
system I understand the point about
interoperability so that people can go
from one state to the other the same
vehicle using the same system but we
have nationwide computer systems we have
a nationwide telephone system but nobody
would call these national systems in
Europe which you did not mention they've
done a lot of work on this and they have
an interoperable system for Europe which
does not require every country to have
the same system yeah I agree I I don't
think a national system is the place to
start nor isn't even remotely likely to
start there that you know the interest
in the action and the progress is all at
the state level and so that feeds
naturally I think into an interoperable
but diverse system which is gives us the
most experimentation the most chance to
learn from success and failure I think
that you raised a very good point and I
know in Europe I think the place where
this is how
right now is in truck called Trek VMT in
Germany which is slightly different from
what we're talking about i think the
reason why that people that we stuck
with and of course of our research were
looking at a national system must be
because of the fact they see it as a way
to replace any national funding
mechanism for transportation so it
doesn't necessarily have to be that but
that's the view or the perspective of
the people that we interviewed at my
research that raises a good point that I
didn't think of which is you know my
vision for this I think of the majority
of people who are working on this at
least see it at right now as is this is
a replacement for the gas tax is kind of
discussed the starting point which means
it's going to have to replace the
federal gas tax at some point unless you
get rid of a federal gas tax in the
interim so ultimately you do have to
have a national version of this but I
don't think that's where you start I
think that's where you finish not how to
see a calm and I've done some work in
Europe including in Germany in Poland
and I do appreciate obviously there the
vehicle miles traveled systems do only
apply to trucks and commercial vehicles
but nonetheless the technological
challenges and issues of privacy aren't
completely dissimilar so what would you
say the top three lessons that you can
learn from those projects which after
all now on are just pilots but actually
active in many judgments reasonably
successful versions of the kind of
system you're thinking about for the USA
at Johanna mostly
thank you well as far as I know there's
just the one system in Germany I know
the Netherlands was considering a system
that they they actually aborted their
planning in that in the last year once
not to employment about a month ago oh
okay well that's news that's nice to
hear we don't have any lessons from now
I think I think there is a difference
especially when you're talking about
privacy between other that between a
system that is focused on commercial
truck someone that's focused on
passenger vehicles I think the personal
space of people is a little different
ending right now even here in the US we
have the truck fleets that are tracked
by gps for business and commercial
reasons and i think people who are
operators of those trucks can understand
and to some degree agree with that i
think that we get into privacy issues
when we start talking about individuals
and individual privacy i think a
wonderful piece of research and its
research that actually the oxford
internet institute is conducting right
now is looking at the changing
perspectives of privacy that is
happening I mean we talk about privacy
as as it if it's a absolute and I think
privacy is very relative I think it's
relative to context its relative to
situation its relative to perhaps even
age cohorts i don't know but i don't
think i think until we start sort of to
get disentangling some of these concepts
of privacy we really won't be able to
answer those questions I just add
University of Iowa did one of these
trials on this here in the US and in the
process of doing that they began with
Willie to begin with the early on they
did a whole bunch of focus groups and
one of the
discussions they had in those focus
groups was about privacy and pursuant to
it johanna said about perceptions of
privacy they drilled into well you know
the thing that a lot of people in this
business like to say is when people talk
about tracking they say well don't you
know you have a cell phone in your
pocket and that is the best tracking
device we have outside of the CIA it
tracks you much more accurately than
most conceivable vehicular based systems
do and people in these focus groups were
pretty straightforward they're like yeah
but verizon can't throw me in jail for
doing something that they don't like and
if they did mess with me i could go to
the government and get them to stop if
the government is tracking me i got
nowhere to go so they make a real
distinction between giving up their
privacy in a commercial setting with the
their choices that they have in that
setting and the recourse to the law they
have versus giving up their privacy to
the government and the relative lack of
those things that they have there so
that's yet another distinction as well
as just the fact that we have a
generational difference in perceptions
of privacy broadly and all of this but
circling right back to your question
about journey because commercial
vehicles are so different from private
vehicles individual vehicles what we're
really learning a walk in Germany is on
the administrative side we've learned a
lot about enforcement they've pretty
dramatically overhauled their
enforcement system based on what
happened in the real world a lot of
their administrative happy how to make
the administrative system in the
collection system more efficient it's
great for that and we'll certainly
hopefully everyone will be capitalizing
on that
College Deborah Madeline from Louis
Bircher you seem to treat every mile as
equivalent to every other mile and I was
already being considered for example
like more congestion pricing so that if
you're going into a heavily traveled
area you might be a higher fee than if
you were just out on the open road let
me answer that by getting some
information that i didn't mention my
presentation and perhaps i should about
the first study that we did where we
assess the different VMT monitoring
devices and when we were looking at
those eight different types of devices
one of the goals of that was to see how
well each tract measured and estimate
estimated mileage area of travel route
of travel time of travel as well as
salient vehicle characteristic so I
didn't go into her lack of time but the
report that we have actually goes into
each of those different monitoring
devices and rates each on how well it
does each of those and there are you
know obviously one of the benefits of
GPS as opposed to say an odometer based
system is that it would allow you to do
something like adjust
base price pricing because you would you
would be able to monitor bft by time of
day it would also let you do facility
based pricing because it would allow you
to monitor route of travel some of the
devices like the avi the automatic
vehicle identification devices only
allow you to monitor area travel so
depending on what you're looking at
there are cost implications for all that
if we were doing a statewide or a
national system yeah I mean if there's a
lot of complexities there it's just like
if you if you actually look at your
phone bill in detail I mean most people
focus on like the amount they pay for
calls and not so much on like all the
things that they pay that aren't
directly related to the amount of calls
they do but you're when you pay your
phone bill you're actually paying for a
whole bundle of things and we sort of
except that it's you know it's a bit of
a challenge when you're talking about
transportation the starting point for
the gas tax is charging people for the
infrastructure they're using so clearly
that would be the starting point for a
mileage based system the technology
would allow charging for you know I you
could pay if you're on a county road
money goes to the county if you're on a
city road the money goes the city if
you're on the state road you know you
get the picture right so it could be the
money could flow based on who owns and
therefore maintains the road you drive
on it could be congestion priced it
could be if your vehicle is heavier you
pay more if I mean obviously cars a
thousand pounds heavier doesn't really
do more damage the robotic car this
vehicle it's 10,000 pounds heavier
doesn't do more damage through all these
things are possible but you don't start
there because it's going to be hard
enough for people to grok just changing
from gas tax to paling by the mile I
think let's get over that hurdle before
we start trying to refine this into the
ultimate pricing mechanism
hi Kailen Doolin from Kittleson um I'm
wondering I'm curious too and this is
kind of related I guess to the last
question but with the differences in
your mind and the pros of a user base
fee over saying congestion tax which we
know has been used in London it was
trying to be they tried to implement it
in New York City before and failed but
it's a smaller scale it's more likely I
think to be successful because you don't
have this idea of privacy and it could
actually take people that commute from
their suburban homes and by car that
actually do have these transit lines
into the city so why are we talking
about user base fees that are this huge
natural system versus something it would
be more simpler like a congestion tax
well we're not talking about them in to
the exclusion there's lots of
conversations going on about things like
congestion courtney charges there's many
pros and cons to congestion gordon
charges that we don't want to get into
tonight it's yet another mechanism out
there for dealing with congestion it is
not actually anywhere that i've seen
being considered as a mechanism
primarily to pay for the infrastructure
so we're we're kind of trying to solve
different problems in these two
different discussions but you're right
you I would exactly expand on your point
to say we're talking about this sort of
long-run transition in the core
mechanism for funding transportation at
the same time there's dozens of other
major transitions going on in not just
in transportation funding but in
transportation service transmission
policymaking in and service you know so
yeah all these things are going to mix
and match
hopefully mixing relatively better and
not conflicting 20 if over the next 20
years there's more toll roads more hot
lanes more congestion cordons in the
u.s. when a mileage based system rolls
out it's got to incorporate all of those
right so somehow the charging system
just has to take into account and
accommodate all of that as well so it
adds to the complexity for sure aimee
custis transportation learning center I
work primarily at transit and I am
always curious when I hear about VMT and
buff discussions about what we're
talking about this to replace how we are
federally funding transportation it
seems a logical extension to me that one
of the big arguments for or against it
depending on what side you're on is that
it doesn't have to be limited simply to
automobiles the way the gas tax has been
and I'm just curious as to why that's
not something that is more on the table
I mean just to take a local example we
already track how far you go when you
guide Washington metro and that's what
your fare is based on so why is this not
something that's being talked about in
the context of n buff in bmt
that's a really interesting question I
think it has to do with a related
question that is whether mileage-based
user fees will be done at the exclusion
of other time you know how do we
transition to any kind of new fee system
so I think at some point we will if this
does continue that we and goes to its
logical endpoint that all vehicles would
be somehow charged by the by the miles
used but I think in the transition to
that there will be these either
voluntary or somewhat multiple parallel
sources of collecting the funds or the
revenues that are going on I think the
reason why you don't hear about it as
much is because there is so much
complexity and debate of simply talking
about automobiles or vehicles that I
think you know that sort of gets left in
the fray so to speak
last question I'm Darrell Ward I'm with
strata calm and if you're not familiar
at home we do communications outreach
around lots of these problems problems
projects Freudian slip there this would
be a very challenging communications
project and I mean I came up with
several questions but I'm going to focus
on we're asking people to pay yes for
something that they only pay for
something that they use where today I
pay a lot of taxes for a lot of things
that I don't use I don't have children
my taxes still go to public school
systems I've never used any social
services my text is still pay for
welfare so how long until we're only
paying taxes or fees for things that we
use should we implement a vm t and has
that come into consideration just
because this has been something that the
government has always just provided to
us yeah that's the there has always been
a question about whether any given thing
the government does should be funded
with attacks the way we pay for
education or a fee the way we pay for
say parks for the most part or
transportation with the with the gas tax
which is functions as a tax though it's
much more like a user fee than most
taxes are but it's not as much like a
fee as an actual fida so it's it's an
in-between this would be actually a
movement to a fee so the advantage that
has is worse the close relationship
who uses pays you know the disadvantage
is if you like the idea of people not
using the system helping pay for it then
that would be a disadvantage right
though you know transportations one of
those things where the trucks that bring
you everything you consume will be
paying that fee so it'll be embedded in
the prices of all the goods that you
purchase the services that you purchase
and so forth so few people will live
their lives without contributing pretty
much proportionally to the amount they
benefit from the roads that's the beauty
of fees taxes have no such Nexus and you
may or may not benefit from any given
tax you pay because they're just not
structured that way so moving
transportation keeping transportation as
user fee in fact making it a better user
fee doesn't fundamentally undermine all
the things we pay for with taxes because
we do believe they're more general and
redistributionist in nature you know and
that's the way we do it I just wanted to
add that you actually mean a very good
point and I think that those of those
people that are looking at these issues
know that it's both a policy issue a
technical issue and a communication
issue and some people even think the
communication part of it is the most
important because you really have a
moving window and you have a moving
window of changing policies and thoughts
and strategies for how this might move
forward but at the same time you have
the necessity to communicate about it
and since you're in communications I'm
sure you understand how difficult it is
to communicate when you know what you're
communicating as opposed to
communicating about something that is
morphing as you're going forward okay
let's give them a big hand and
this ticket had come up in model we've
got food and drinks and enjoy feel free
to stay